but we begin with an american tradition
on this black friday tens of millions of
americans will be shopping online and in
stores after celebrating thanksgiving
this was the scene before sunrise at a
best buy store in woodland park new
jersey which opened to waiting customers
at five in the morning five in the
morning shoppers already spent at least
three and a half million dollars per
minute online yesterday that's according
to adobe analytics more than 108 million
people plan the shop in stores or online
today experts predict a new record in
spending over the holiday season meg
oliver is inside that best buy in new
jersey meg good morning i hope you're
safe
i am safe good morning vlad well today
is officially black friday best buy
started rolling out black friday deals
in october with more sales launching a
week ago but as you mentioned that
didn't stop shoppers from turning out
early today looking for bargains
pre-pandemic stores like this one would
have been opened on thanksgiving day
facing potential supply shortages many
retailers started their holiday sales in
october and have made black friday a
weeks-long event
i'm looking for a laptop
and some other like little electronics
and stuff this morning eager shoppers
looking for the best deals lined up in
the dark just like the old days
i got it
i did it big box stores aren't the only
ones cashing in business has been really
really good marco sejal owns wachong
book sellers in new jersey she says
after struggling to stay open during the
pandemic she's grateful so many
customers have returned in person how
important is black friday to your bottom
line so we used to ignore black friday
but
10 years ago we said you know what we're
going to embrace black friday and we
called it festivus friday so it's become
a really strong day
for us and a fun day well she's not sure
what the it book will be this year say
gel says she and her team are planning
ahead to keep shelves stocked throughout
the holidays we are concerned about the
last
massive two-week rush and having enough
product with the supply chain so we've
been encouraging people to shop early
and they are about 60 percent of
shoppers said they've already begun
their holiday shopping that's no
surprise with so many stores trying to
entice shoppers to start spending early
with sales offering early access to
deals we've been seeing consumers start
earlier and earlier every year catherine
cullen is with the national retail
federation they predict that holiday
sales during november and december will
grow up to 10.5 percent over 2020 and
consumers will spend up to 859 billion
dollars setting records for both growth
and total amount spent individual
consumers said they plan to spend about
one thousand dollars total this holiday
season it seems like black friday sales
started after halloween they have been
offering their deals earlier and earlier
you know a couple years ago we were
talking about black november
now we're seeing black friday deals
starting in october and really in those
weeks leading up to thanksgiving
in-person shopping is up more than 14
this year and it's expected about 160
million people are expected to shop over
this holiday weekend that includes cyber
monday so if you're looking for
something specific the message from big
and small retailers michelle bye early
yeah did you get yours in
i got it all in i got here early i've
been shopping a little bit
we love hearing that meg so glad he
could do two things at once